um good evening
everyone I'm here together with the
honorable president of the European
commission that among other
things is a very precious
friend and a supporter of
Albania from the first hours of
her mandate at the Helm of the European
commission
not by
words but
by standing by us along this entire
Journey and I will never
forget and will
always repeat it as long as I will be in
this office that she stood by our
side at a tragic moment for our country
and our
people
when the
devastating
earthquake brought so much pain and
inflicted so much pain and so many
damages without the president of the
commission without her
personal direct
commitment to
call so
swiftly a major conference in Brussels
and ask solidarity from each and
everyone we would not have made it as we
did
and tens and hundreds of thousands of
children
who lost their schools during that
earthquake would not be
learning and studying today in schools
that actually are no different from any
of the best schools of the European
Union
however we are here today together with
a president for de liion in the wake of
another Summit to be held in Tana this
time the first Berlin process Summit to
take place after outside of the European
Union borders which indeed sees us proud
and provides
us with the
opportunity to
express
our pleasure as a host country and make
us show all the power of our Albanian
Hospitality which
I believe that if a competition were
held across Europe
would very
well aim for the uh for the first place
to be ranked on top however we are quite
aware that there are many other things
that of course see us be quite a f cry
from being ranked on top and it is quite
the other way around that it needs to
see us take the efforts to enter this
perimeter of the standards and of the
quality of life that is inherent to the
European
Union the
president has arrived first out of all
the leaders expected to come later or
even tomorrow
also
because she kick started such an
important event for us
with baing the way to all the girls and
boys in Albania and the region at large
who wish to pursue Advanced European
studies to do so by attending the
College of Europe based Onan
the campus of the College of
Europe in Tana will be the second
outside Belgian Belgium following the
one which the commission at the time
decided to set up in Poland to deal with
the first uh enlargement wave in Europe
and to
help the candidate countries of the time
were their capacity building and I
really believe that the opening of this
Campus of the College of Europe is
connected to the willingness to the
desire and dedication of the president
and the European Union to push further
the enlargement process of this large
United European
family the president informed us
screening on the progress of the
screening process and I'm using this
terminology since I am not very well
informed how it is exactly in
Albanian but since everyone else in all
the countries uh refer to it as
screening then it is screening it is
actually an indepth the surgical
diagnosis of the entire state of play
across all the sectors of the country
that has been approved to negotiate
their membership and I really felt
very good to have heard from the
president a very nice words about the
process and about what Albania has been
doing furthermore I wish to assure you
that the president is not one to only
actually speak niceties or good words
which actually makes her good words even
more meaningful because if she were only
a person of just nice words such nice
words would indeed actually um lose the
meaning coming out from from her of
course we talked about the situation and
the region we spoke of the imperative
for all the countries of the region to
walk hand in hand making use of all the
Bing process capacities we also talked
about what according to me is the most
important novelty in years of the Berlin
process Summit again thanks to the
president who has not uh come to to
merely to repeat things that are already
known but also to introduce a
new plan that
will significantly help the Western
Balkans our countries to move faster
towards the European Union but the
president will talk about it tomorrow in
the summit and I don't know how much you
will want to reveal to you today
therefore I'm not going to uh continue
further in this
respect I do not want to be any
lengthier but I wish to
conclude by the fact that like always
from day one of the Russian aggression
against Ukraine we've been talking about
that matter Albania actually has got a
modest size as a country and a modest
role to play but within our stature and
role
we have
been we are and will remain fully
aligned with the European Union
concerning
Ukraine we will be in the same united
front that is not there merely to
support Ukraine but also a front the
champion the flag of the
non-negotiable principles and values of
this large United Family of countries
who believe in Freedom who believe in
democracy who believe in Justice
and who believe in the unconditional
right of every and each country to
defend their territorial
Integrity Madame President
deula
with a lot of gratitude I wish to thank
you for arriving first and allow me to
tell you that this is a very good omen
for us
because usually the most important
leaders are the last to come and the
Very fact that you were the first to
come
shows enter
earlier that
although that have been several
years in which you are trying to do the
best for us you have the same ambition
and willingness just like in your day
one
thank you very
much I
have
for
our
[Music]
for
the
con
fact
uh
for
hold on a sec for that I'm
ready from ABC News I have two questions
one question to the president of the
commission is the oid agreement was
based on the Franco German plan and
following the latest developments in
Kosovo what is happening to the oid
agreement and for the Prime Minister Mr
Rama do you expect new developments
tomorrow in relation to the kosova and
Serbia situation given the fact that
after the 24th of September this will be
the first round table where both Prime
Ministers Albin kurti from kosov from
kosov and an barovich from Serbia will
be
there
[Music]
for
the
process is connected to the constant
encouragement of all the countries of
the region to go toward the four
European Union freedoms
the freedom of mov m m of
people Goods capitals and
services
typically the process at hand and its
Summits
thereof are not the venue to
address the bilateral issues
nonetheless the SU agenda that uh has
been prepared since long ago in tandem
in cooperation with the German
Chancellor's office the leaders working
lunch
will be focused also on the neighborly
relations in the
region so the room
for an open
exchange among the uh participants has
been scheduled
already
however it is not a summit that takes
upon
itself to find solutions to problems
which as the
president mentioned on this matter are
issues that are addressed and
should be solved Under the Umbrella of
the European
Union Dan mil
repor I have a common question a joint
question for the president and the Prime
Minister it is to be underlined that the
summit comes uh in a tense situation
both for the region and the World At
Large you touched a on it in your answer
Mr Rama but will there be a statement
after the summit on the events in covo
in particular on the September 24th
event where a police officer from Kosovo
was killed additionally is there going
to be a joint statement after the summit
on what is happening in the Gaza Strip
where a humanitarian crisis risks to
happen thank you
yeah
so as far as I
understand
human
re
once again Tana
Summit is
under the berin process and uh
continuation of its Summits the bin
process is a vision forged by Chancellor
Angela
Merkel who for the first first
time in all our history and by that I
refer to all the countries of the
region she made it possible for all the
Western bcans leaders to come together
around a table just like
um it never happened in history it was
actually a first not only to talk about
the
past and not to talk about the past but
to Kickstart a cooperation for the
future such future cooperation has been
uh defined within the framework of the
four EU freedoms which I mentioned
earlier that provide countries with the
opportunity to harness their potential
to a much larger degree while at the
same time they um Mak stri
each and every one of them in their own
Journey towards the European Union so
all efforts go to this direction in the
meantime
even under the circumstances where the
situation of the world is much more
fraught with issues as compared to 10 or
five or some years ago the European
Union has taken a leadership role under
the president under the uh presidency of
the Madame President to bring a concrete
and very important
contribution which actually is a
novelty following the the the family
picture in the first meeting in berin
this is the the greatest nobley the
growth plan that provides countries an
opportunity of course against the reform
forms they have to um carry
out first to access an extra funding of
the European Union and on the other hand
to be given new room in the single
European market which is a significant
impetus for our
economies within that
framework
even
much earlier than
what has recently happened and you
mentioned in your question that is the
brutally revived conflict between uh the
pal Palestine and Israel we have um
established a slot to
discuss the unly um relations in the
region but nothing more than that this
is not the purpose of this Summit at all
indeed Tana is the European capital city
of the balans but it's not the navel of
Europe actually politically
geographically we can talk about that
but then we will have to enter a
conflict with Greeks the serbians with
macedonians
monans to establish which is the navel
of Europe physically but politically be
sure none of us is the navel of Europe
is in Brussels that is where everything
is discussed and where they decide about
this topics that are
actually quite bigger than we are we are
honored to be together with this family
and actually to tell you the truth we
don't have even the terrible heada AE
when it comes to the decisions that
should be taken in a dramatic situation
that is a headache that the president
and the European union leaders have so
we try to make it easier for them if
they ask us to give an opinion okay but
if not it's not up to us and tana to
address and solve the problems of the
planet can we take another
question gu I I believe there is someone
there thank you I have the same question
can you introduce yourself to the for
the president because I know
you from the Albanian
correspondent dear Madam
president what is the essence of the
criteria you will set for the
distribution or allocation of the funds
under the uh growth
plan under a situation where we have a
new
geostrategic moment considering the
interest of the European commission and
the interests of the region but also
considering the the demand of the
citizens to have tangible results from
such plan Mr Prime Minister how will
your government respond to this offer or
to this
new plan of growth to absorb at the
funding Albania needs to continue its
progress on its path towards the
European Union thank you so the history
of the
European
for typal
situation right now
the
for
more often than not we actually tie the
European Union the European commission
the process to the
funding they are very important and
there is no doubt that the European
Union
is the most secure safety belt for all
those countries part of the European
Community which as you have witnessed
when lar crisis hit just like the
pandemic or the um energy spiking
crisis uh
hit
actually
benefit quite largely as far as our
countries are
concerned in
addition to what it is per se the
European Union is not a gift
shop it is the most
sophisticated and most difficult
democratic State Building
School in the region we are countries
with an extremely poor tradition when it
comes to uh the institutional framework
and perhaps
Albania is one which even compar to the
countries of the region has had to face
a history that has deterred and has not
helped the establishment of a States and
institutions for centuries in
the European Union is our biggest
blessing to have a democratic State
functioning
institutions that
enable the implementation of the values
and standards of the European Union in
our
country and this schooling process the
European Union offers scholarships these
actually are
scholarships these are not the funds
being given to member countries so this
is a new scholarship program but uh as
the uh director of the College of Europe
said today are offered to those who
Excel considering
also
the need to help those who actually are
most in need for such assistance as we
are in the region so this is not a sack
full of money that were put in and now
are going to be
distributed it is a relationship giving
us a new opportunity for
funding therefore on the other hand we
need to be the best at our homework so
that we can get the most of such
financing nothing comes
merely because something is
signed even more so the European Union
can actually give it to you tell tell
you here you here you are here you have
it and you may never have it because it
is you who have to go and get it so in
this on this note this is a very
positive development and will allow us
to push further with our efforts because
if the European
Union
asks
and insists that the Bine
process is made tangible within the
perameter of our countries as a process
that ensures an enhancement of such
freedoms of movement of people of goods
and so on and so forth and if it tells
us on the other hand that you could have
increased access into the single Market
we can forget it to have such access
without meeting our own obligation here
with the region so you can't Levy fees
or actually uh put blockages in the
borders because this is how you think
about it within the region and then go
to have the same access into the single
European
market these are all
incentives these are a significant
novelty that is a result of the
political Spirit of this European
commission which the president has
mentioned since the day one of the
commission yes because we are used in
Albania since uh since we were young to
read leaders and to take notes of what
they they write so it is up to us now it
is up to us now to do our homework that
is where the challenge lies not actually
do our homework because we need to have
the commission like us or to have the
Berlin Chancellor's office like
it is something that we have to do for
the future of this country thank you
very
[Music]
much